what up space fam goes in here from
anime Opera with the latest and craziest
developments in the one piece story and
oh my there is a lot to talk about here
from Kuma's destination to arriving at
albaf to Zoro fighting to GARP and
Blackbeard and so much more so make sure
to stay tuned for what must be one of
the most busy chapters in one piece of
all time Channel pirate king within and
smash that like button if you enjoy
seeing these one piece reviews and want
to keep them coming be a smashing pirate
king rather than passing Orochi in the
universe will reward you accordingly and
hit that subscribe button below the
video to join the nakama so you don't
miss future one piece videos and updates
over half of the people watching these
videos aren't subscribed so let's try to
get that subscribe percentage up and
I'll let you know if we succeed and now
without further Ado let's jump into It
spoilers and all so this chapter is
called a hero's offensive and oh boy
will it ever deliver when we get to that
part but for now we see Kuma flying
through the air and we find out that he
ends up in redport the base of the red
line people freak out that it's Kuma and
comment on how they heard he fled the
Holy Land remember that Marie is located
on the red line they call him the
celestial dragon's invisible slave and I
definitely would like to see him get
some revenge on Celestial dragons but I
feel like Kuma probably has something
more important in mind all available
Marines are ordered to be deployed where
Kuma is and civilians are advised that
he's extremely dangerous he's called a
man with no shred of humanity and it's
added that his current purpose and
programming is unknown Oda is really
doing a good job of hyping up the
mystery around Kuma here what do you
think is his goal right now let me know
in the comments anyways we then jump
back to Egghead and although cp0 is
trying to surround our guys even with
the seraphims under their control now
they can't get to our guys because of
the nuisance that is the frontier Dome
Kaku calls it a Marvel and it goes to
show the power of science to actually
pose a problem for strong characters
Luchi is asked if he's determined to
ignore the Navy and Luchi response that
he refuses to accept Straw Hat as an
emperor which is hilarious to me it's
definitely because of his personal
history with him but I like seeing such
individuality within the Marine greens
it would be boring if they all just
followed orders and speaking of not
falling orders just wait for it it's
gonna get crazy we then jump to the
different punks arguing what they should
do and then another allies brought up
who is on the island another intriguing
mystery it said that they shouldn't call
them because then they'd be risking
their lives and they'd have nowhere left
to hide if they're in the government
sites too but main body vegapunk doesn't
hesitate to call and ask for help and
the voice says of course and that
they've been prepared for this order so
intriguing man and it's nice to see that
our side seems to be getting some help
since the last few chapters with the
seraphim's drawing cp0 and keys are
arriving were all about the Marines
getting in a better and better situation
this figure seems to be a big deal since
it said Escape should be a piece of cake
now with them on board all they gotta do
is just keep cp0 busy Lilith says she'll
take them to port with Megaforce one and
it's hilarious that it took me actually
reading out loud while recording this to
realize that it sounds like Air Force
One that's hilarious but anyways that's
where they can presumably get on the
straw hat ship and in another hilarious
moment Daft Punk says I approve only for
Lilith to say who put you in charge love
that even these satellites have so much
personality and fleshed out Dynamics and
it's definitely understandable between a
number one and number two vegapunk then
gets packed and asks them to take all
seven of them to the ship although I
personally doubt that they'll all make
it on board for sanji's sake though I
hope Lilith does make it and I just love
to see how hyped up Frankie is about
traveling with the seven faces of the
world's best scientist vegapunk is like
his mihawk then we jump to Bonnie trying
to hunt down vegapunk and Luffy chasing
after her telling her that he promised
to get the old-timer out of here in one
piece and yes they just said the title
of the show in the chapter coincidence
probably and if you want Bonnie to join
the crew like me let everyone know by
Smashing that like button let's see how
much of us there are but then another
shocking thing happens the frontier
defenses go offline why I have no idea
the punks are wondering who would
disable it and for what reason and they
are told that no one is picking up
anything in the control room so another
mystery presents itself interestingly
enough Luchi is the one who thinks it
might be a trap since it seems so
convenient and yeah it is insanely
convenient for them to be sure to the
point where Oda better have a good
explanation for it soon I mean yes it's
more interesting if a conflict happens
but at the same time it's unrealistic so
there has to be a good reason they try
and everything seems okay so they
conclude that the heavens must have
abandoned vegapunk they arrive at the
straw hat ship so this seems to be where
things will go down since the straw hats
are headed there too Kaku goes to
destroy the ship and he has the most
confident satisfied smirk as he's about
to do it and it's so satisfying for me
when we see Zorro wake up from his nap
and slash away his attack like it was
nothing immediately Kaku gets upset and
you love to see the change in expression
xor is irritated that someone
interrupted his nap man he's so cool
whereas Kaku looks shocked and like he
fears for his life Sweat Beads pouring
down his face and everything and I'm
hyped because I always get get excited
about Zorro fights and Zorro action
sometimes even more excited than Luffy
action I gotta say the satellites get
the frontier Dome back online but the
cp0 agents have already infiltrated and
our guys know that they'll Target the
ship it's so good that Zoro is there
though I have no fear of them destroying
it with Zorro there to protect it not at
all Luffy and Chopper are finally
reunited with the rest of the crew and
Luffy is kind of upset that they are
rushing to leave after they just arrived
to this really cool place and then
people notice that Bonnie is missing and
so is surprise surprise vegapunk 100
points to anyone who can guess why
they're missing but then it's revealed
when we jump to vegapunk running for his
life and saying they're in a rush
however Bonnie is not having any of it
she asks if he can turn her dad back to
normal yes or no and we get another clue
when vegapunk says no but that there is
a reason for that he even wanted to
explain but so far Bonnie isn't hearing
him out so hopefully soon we'll get the
truth behind Kuma revealed then what is
maybe the most high part of the chapter
we see kid and his crew and they end end
up at the home of giants elbaf this is
so hyped to me in part because the one
piece Community has been hyping up the
al-bath arc for so long and associating
Shanks with it so not only is this
exciting because kid has history with
Shanks but also because it could be the
beginning of a much hyped up al-bath Arc
or at least teasing it but as if that
wasn't a good place to end Oda gives us
another hype detail that is arguably
even more hype we get garpa being GARP
and that's always a good thing we figure
out that he wants to launch an offensive
against an emperor and when he's asked
if he ran it by people in charge he said
why would he such an epic response this
dude must be the top three coolest in
the series I must say it's also pointed
out that he survived in the Navy for
decades with that attitude such a boss
such a boss such a boss he just says
don't worry about it and it's revealed
he's at G14 but he's not going to nearby
Egghead instead he meets up with
helmeppo who's crying about Kobe still
GARP says stop whimpering it's hard to
watch and get on board to helmeppo he
says they are going to Pirate Island
Blackbeard's HQ he says let's beat the
snot out of those pirates and save
Captain Kobe and wow that is huge the
hero of the Marines GARP the one alluded
to in the title of the chapter which was
a hero's offensive how mepo starts
crying even harder in the face of such
awesomeness in the context of the story
I feel like this conflict may be a way
for Oda to Hype up Blackbeard even more
but either way this is as hype as it
gets GARP is past his prime yes but he's
still a living legend and a half and I
can't wait to see how Oda deals with
this situation and we got to keep in
mind GARP is not just ignoring the Navy
he's also going after another Emperor
Blackbeard who is an antagonist to Luffy
and Luffy obviously wants to save Kobe
too so this is pretty much like GARP
just teaming up with Luffy right now and
the implications are so hype I can't
even explain them all right here however
even a legend like GARP will have
trouble with the Blackbeard Pirates and
if you want to know why don't miss my
video about all 16 Blackbeard pirates
and their powers explained link on
screen right now and in the description